y
[Música]
la vacuna contra el hobby 19 del
laboratorio estadounidense novavax en
recibió el aval de los entes reguladores
de europa tanto la ema como la comisión
europea autorizaron su aplicación de
emergencia a mayores de 18 años el
laboratorio podría empezar a
distribuirla en el 'viejo continente' a
partir del mes de enero
los mercados reaccionaron a la baja como
respuesta a la elección del izquierdista
gabriel boric como nuevo presidente de
chile el ex líder estudiantil apuesta
por un sistema de bienestar similar al
europeo y genera incertidumbre sobre el
destino que podría tener la propiedad
privada y el empresariado durante su
gobierno
de argentina conmemora 20 años del
inicio del estallido social que terminó
con el gobierno del presidente fernando
de la rúa en medio de una profunda
crisis económica que dio paso al llamado
corralito financiero miles de personas
se dieron cita para recordar también a
las 39 víctimas mortales que dejó la
represión policial tenemos los detalles
desde buenos aires
muy buenas tardes bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 soy santiago lópez
gonzález gracias por estar con nosotros
hasta ahora vamos a comenzar en el
continente europeo la ema que es la
agencia europea del medicamento respaldo
el uso de la vacuna estadounidense
novavax de principio proteínico para
combatir el kobe de 19 nuevas sería
entonces la quinta vacuna en superar
este filtro por parte de las autoridades
médicas europeas y es también la primera
vacuna basada en proteínas recomendada
para combatir el kobe 19 en mayores de
18 años la unión europea indicó que
apoyará a todas las campañas de
vacunación en los estados miembros y
acordó también una compra de lotes de
vacunas para el bloque para los 27
países que conforman la unión europea
los resultados de los estudios muestran
una eficacia de la vacuna para novak
súbita de alrededor de 90% la cepa
original del sar co2 y algunas variantes
preocupantes como alfa y beta fueron las
más comunes que circulaban cuando los
estudios estuvieron en curso actualmente
existen datos limitados sobre la
eficacia de nueva subida frente a otras
variantes de interés incluido o micro y
seguimos en europa porque un tribunal
del reino unido- aceptó en parte el
recurso presentado por la oposición
venezolana con el que pretendía que le
fuera entregado el poder de mil millones
de dólares en oro que tiene venezuela
almacenado en el banco de inglaterra el
tribunal reconoció que juan guaidó que
es el presidente reconocido
internacionalmente por cerca de 50
países tiene el derecho para acceder a
esta reserva de oro sin embargo será la
división comercial del tribunal superior
la que determine en última instancia a
quien autoriza para la entrega de estas
reservas de oro venezolano
y nos vamos ahora esta suramérica
después del triunfo de gabriel boric
quien es ahora el presidente electo de
chile los mercados reaccionaron con
escepticismo a su elección en sus
primeras operaciones de este lunes la
bolsa de santiago tuvo pérdidas de más
del 5% cifras que con el paso de las
horas comenzaron a mejorar mientras que
las acciones de sqm que es una de las
principales mineras de ese país
suramericano se desplomaban ya casi 11
por ciento al inicio de la sesión para
luego recuperarse levemente la moneda
local el peso chileno por su parte
también perdía 13 por ciento frente al
dólar estadounidense al inicio de esta
jornada
gabriel boric a sus 35 años es el
presidente más joven de la historia de
chile y no le tengo miedo a la juventud
para cambiar este país porque también
debemos de la experiencia de quienes
lucharon antes que nosotros un discurso
que buscó a los jóvenes que participaron
en el estallido social de 2019 en
rebeldía contra el conocido como milagro
económico de chile fue la cuna el
neoliberalismo también será
precisamente boris se dio a conocer como
líder estudiantil en 2011 esto le
permitió saltar a la política en 2014
cuando fue escogido diputado de
magallanes la zona más austral y
olvidada de chile de donde es oriundo
su partido convergencia social forma
parte de la coalición frente amplio
junto al partido comunista se convierte
ahora en el presidente más a la
izquierda en chile desde salvador
allende derrocado por un golpe de estado
en 1973 moritz buscará enterrar a la
dictadura militar de augusto pinochet y
su constitución de 1980 representando a
una nueva generación que ha dejado atrás
la histórica centroizquierda de la
concertación e incluso su última
presidenta michelle bachelet pidió votar
por boris
no da lo mismo entonces por qué
candidato se votan por
gabriel bueno es una búsqueda del centro
que se sumó a sus críticas a los
gobiernos de venezuela y nicaragua pero
desde la oposición no se fían y condenan
su reunión en españa con uno de los
asesinos del diputado derechista jaime
guzmán
moritz promete diálogo y recuerda el 15
de noviembre de 2019 cuando fue artífice
del acuerdo que derivó en el actual
proceso constituyente esto le valió
críticas internas en su coalición
mientras sin corbata y remangado ha
logrado ser el presidente de la nueva
constitución
argentina conmemora 20 años del inicio
del estallido sociales que terminó con
el gobierno del presidente fernando de
la rúa en medio de una profunda crisis
económica que también dio paso al
llamado corralito financiero miles de
personas se dieron cita en la
emblemática plaza de mayo en el centro
de buenos aires frente a la casa rosada-
que es la sede del gobierno argentino
para recordar también a las 39 víctimas
mortales que dejaron los choques con la
policía local choques que duraron unas
48 horas para intentar reprimir a los
argentinos natalio cos hoy nos cuenta
más desde buenos aires
en 2001 alicia para él yo trabajaba en
un banco y recuerdas claramente las
protestas de diciembre de ese año cuando
en medio de una gran crisis económica
social y política el gobierno impuso
restricciones al acceso de los ahorros
de los ciudadanos el llamado corralito
esta era una zona de guerra gente
corriendo
y los gases yo lo que me acuerdo eran
los gases que no podía ver lo peor llegó
el 20 de diciembre luego de que el
gobierno decretara el estado de sitio
para intentar poner fin a las protestas
que no se detuvieron una fuerte
represión se desató y cobró la vida de
39 personas entre ellas la pareja de
maría arena gastón venía desde 9 de
julio
hacia por avenida de mayo hacia a
tacuary que es esta esquina
y cuando estaba en la esquina todavía de
9 de julio
un manifestante se acercó y le dijo
espera no vaya solo porque la arrancaba
la moto como para avanzar solo y gastón
le dijo venir súbita
esta persona se subió con él
los 50 metros lo mataron
lo ocurrido en 2001 dejó consecuencias
tan grandes que existe una suerte de
acuerdo en la política argentina para
evitar a toda costa que eso se repita
eso es una pérdida de mínima el que se
propone la política argentina de que no
explote pero la realidad es que igual
hace 10 años que la argentina vive una
micro crisis en cuotas que está
deteriorado en todos los niveles de
ingresos y todo en lo que es el poder de
comprar los argentinos hace un montón
con lo cual la crisis y está sucediendo
igual y yo creo que ese sistema el 2001
está un poco contra las cuerdas
muchos creen que el país no ha terminado
de resolver los grandes desafíos y
deudas que quedaron pendientes desde esa
gran crisis y mariah arena tiene una muy
concreta la justicia 20 años después no
hay nadie preso por la muerte de su
pareja
vamos a cambiar de tema la estrella del
tenis chino peng shuai negó haber sido
agredida sexualmente por un alto
dirigente del partido comunista chino y
declaró que vive libremente los
comentarios los hizo en su primera
entrevista a un medio de comunicación
desde que sus acusaciones desataron
preocupación internacional por su
seguridad sin embargo las declaraciones
no aliviaron las dudas y los
cuestionamientos por parte de la
asociación del tenis femenino veamos
ben swift fue entrevistada en un acto
promocional en shanghai para los juegos
olímpicos de invierno de pekín apareció
junto a la ex estrella de la nba yao
ming cuando un periodista de singapur le
pregunto ella negó haber sido agredida
sexualmente
ante todo debo subrayar que nunca he
dicho ni escrito nada acusando a nadie
de haberme agredido sexualmente ese es
un punto muy importante eso contradice
su denuncia del 2 de noviembre las redes
sociales de que el ex vice primer
ministro chino zhang a all y le había
obligado a mantener relaciones sexuales
en varias ocasiones tras esta acusación
la ex campeona de dobles de wimbledon y
el abierto de francia desapareció de la
vida pública hasta esta sesión de firma
de autógrafos el 21 de noviembre lo que
pone en duda su libertad de movimiento y
su seguridad la preocupación se extendió
por todo el mundo incluyendo la onu la
casa blanca y otras estrellas del tenis
mo la asociación femenina de la
disciplina reaccionó el domingo a su
declaración seguimos pidiendo una
investigación completa justa y
transparente sin censura sobre su
acusación de agresión y la asociación de
tenis femenino ha suspendido todos los
torneos en china incluida hong kong ante
la preocupación por payne el hecho
alimentó las peticiones de boicot a los
juegos de pekín el ministerio de asuntos
exteriores chino ha dicho que el caso se
exageró maliciosamente
es todo por el momento aquí en las
noticias de france 24 siga con nosotros
siga con nuestra programación buenas
tardes
[Música]